si durante el mes de julio las llamas se
cebaron con el oeste de la península
ibérica' ahora mismo el foco de
preocupación aunque no es el único está
puesto en el este de españa donde el
fuego sigue muy activo en dos incendios
que ya han arrasado al menos 16.000
hectáreas en la comunidad valenciana
donde al menos 3.000 personas han sido
evacuadas los incendios además dejan
varios heridos en las últimas horas por
un lado tres bomberos de manera leve y
por otro 11 personas que viajaban en un
tren que pasaba por la zona afectada por
las llamas los pasajeros sufrieron
quemaduras 3 con pronóstico grave al
salir de los vagones por temor a quedar
atrapados por las llamas la compañía de
transporte renfe ha iniciado una
investigación para esclarecer el suceso
aunque se pronostican algunas tormentas
en la zona de los incendios que
ayudarían a controlar el fuego el viento
sigue con rachas que dificultan las
labores de extinción en las que trabajan
más de mil efectivos españa sigue así
rompiendo récords de superficie quemada
y ya son al menos 274 mil 300 hectáreas
en lo que va de año la gran mayoría de
estas dieron desde junio impulsadas por
la primera ola de calor que sufrió el
país estas cifras que provienen de los
satélites europeos harían de 2022 el
peor año en extensión calcinada desde al
menos
1994 y lo peor es que en españa aún
queda mucho verano por delante